siamo live siamo l'attenzione my boys
aspettiamo qualche secondo che si
connettono tutti ciao carisch orari
buongiorno a tutti regalo un giorno a
tutti adesso ne va sul link subito
adesso ti passo passo tutto ciao ragazzi
buongiorno buongiorno a tutti
ho messo stoffa screenato te l'ho
mandato a vendere bellissimo rega
buongiorno un giorno a tutti buongiorno
ai tre prove siamo dai più folle quella
di oggi live folle oggi ragazzi facciamo
un casino
oggi fanno un casino aspettiamo due
minuti che riconnette che si connettono
tutti che vi con dichiato io però stavo
sbiascicando allora ve la dico al volo
signori oggi a niente
adesso arrivano tutti i ragazzi adesso
ve la spiego lega allora al volo oggi
giochiamo a due giochi importanti fao
mezz'oretta superstars e mezz'oretta su
rocket league
adesso tutti lo ripeteremo una seconda
volta però intanto anche a voi che sono
capite un cazzo di quello che succede
allora mezzate libro stata letta su uno
che ti riduco di buon grassi che oggi vi
accompagna per allenare e con la grazia
prima volta quindi sul canale mio no
correndo la prima volta in esclusiva
grazie a foto mega esclusiva grazie cosa
con che unisce vodacom unisce di youtube
questo caso non si sa chi guarda che è
una donazione ok finché san andrea rock
e se questa cosa delle donne sensibile
ds è il nicola mastronicola secolo e
dall'alto cognome con quel nome ti
voglio bene mi copro grazie
come diciamo caro stavo dicendo oggi
giochiamo a brown stars che è il regno
di graz è poco confidente però
dall'altra parte tosta che poi quella
stoffa sotto e vabbè mattina se
tranquillo tanto nessuno ma ci sta ha
giudicato e come giochiamo
l'importante è che ci divertiamo e poi
io giocherò io giocherò abruzzo adesso e
dopo di che giocherà grazie a rocket
quindi bene sul mio proprio questa la
vodafone swap challenge 2.0 ragazzi
perché la prima se vi ricordate
non so se hai avuto modo di vedere la
tua grazia l'avevo fatta con il signor
power e avevamo fatto cod
ero che click invece adesso adesso c'è
questa cosa qua
sì diciamo oggi i roghi è un po più
incentrata sul mobile visto che vi
ringraziamo ragazzi voi la fanno per
questa grandissima opportunità diciamo
che viviamo fare in un momento un po
strano noi siamo per fare fiere milano
roma in giro per tutta italia
quest'anno in occasione della milano
games week che è una fiera abbastanza
importante vodafone ha già proposto
questa challenge che faremo insieme e
non giocheremo a caso abbastanza perché
vodafone
sappiamo bene ve lo ricordate tante
volte c'è un'offerta perfetta per noi
giocatori mobil perché considera anche
blue stars che la jolie al rilascio
plans lavoro con power gaming ci
permette di giocare i nostri giochi
mobile favino sara conoscevi che avevo
in maniera del tutto senza consumare g
cioè non ti pronti di ricerca che
all'inizio pensavo che fosse diretta
solo a power a giorgio che favorire
invece no è diretta a tutti e tutti la
potete fare voi da forziamo anche crocs
che anche gratis e gaming lesa gioco
solo 20 giocati ti definiscono per lui
perché ogni tanto gracchi grazie
gracchia dai va bene che hanno mandate
nella ripresa
ok quindi boa posto tiri non però più
lontano magari che alzo io da qua così
almeno video nostro problema prova prova
approccio ma è bravo siamo tutti
secondo me abbiamo risolto niente allora
ragazzi è il momento di partire allora
faremo mezzo a rigor di odori ricordo
faremo mezz'oretta più o meno di brown
stars e poi facciamo una pausa in questa
pausa il profilo di vodafone ha raccolto
delle domande che voi potete farci
potete ancora farcela ragazzi misteriori
in tempo state superiori volevo potete
facile e noi che nelle nostre storie
così esatto esatto e noi tra una pausa e
l'altra
scusatemi strangio che l'altro vice la
pausa leggeremo le
le domande e risponderemo ai ragazzi
anche verso la fine faremo questo modo
bene allora io ringrazio prima di
partire al volo giovanni agostino simone
e serve tz lori arianna zitta e per il
supporto e direi che possiamo cominciare
con questa incredibile che in cui si
crede che invece di due che faremo che
su browse
io e farli vedere un attimo un account
gli faccio vedere account il tuo il mio
il tuo speriamo miu miu fa ridere sia
allora scusate ma io ne ho quattro o
cinque valori e show shelley imita colt
bull bombardino e rosa bassa non ho più
la cosa bella è che poi sta sopra le
coppe ma sotto affari non c'era cifre
più severamente 400 negozi sono 400
coppie sono 400 copie giorno altre volte
con nichi che nel mio socio capito e
quindi va bene va bene senti fai tu che
cosa ti devo dire fai tu e io la
vogliamo partire con le tue siamo in
duro possiamo giocare in due
il problema di questo gioco quale è
anche non è che ci mette più o meno
contro player alla nostra portata
contra solamente le coppie di quello che
ci va più alte
allora sì sì certo come rocket league
uguale esatto andremo a 657 e io penso
che presto sentiti e siamo qua per
allora allora senti un attimo ascolta me
tanto mi capita spesso di sta situazione
qualche con l'obiettivo non è vincere
dente favi non lo so non si sentono mi
sento io non ho simi si sente 100 100 sa
che non mi sento io
dicono che lei non si sente devo alzare
un po grazie no si sente risi
ho letto anche giulio o che lo aspetta
al dialogo
alza un pò grazia bene balzo al massimo
pistor disco io lo sento ma che non ti
distruggo io avessi visto ungendo
lorenzo si sente tutto ottenere
dell'alimento non ragazzi mi mentite si
sente benissimo io mi sto chiedendo
vabbè allora
ma il massimo che che posso mettere di
craxi l'ho messo quindi se uno io io
muoio sala non voglio che l'artista non
meglio il lavoro che stavo dicendo
fallito l'obiettivo non è tanto fare
vincere e vincerne una
una è vero che è quello va bene va bene
quello visto che io non so una mazza
quindi va bene alla partenza e con io
vorrei selezionare come si cambia bravo
l'arquà visto come sociale clicca
proprio il browser
adesso qua e mettiamo parte lo posso
migliora bombardino e miglioriamo no è
che abbiamo ce lo vado a fare se non
permette il cash for cash e sennò quale
a totti di rocky e la mappa che ci oggi
per bombardini normale per ballavano a
livello 4 non lo so però ecco ecco me la
devi spiegare stato ma scusa un attimo
ma com'è che più giochi e più di aumenti
il livello del browser ma la scusa uno
che abbia iniziato a giocare
cioè nel deretano subito perché io come
faccio io oppure già teso scarso che non
ho mai giocato pure che cio le
statistiche come c'è un problema è che
devi presente giocare da solo oppure
giocare con player del novecento certo
se entri in queste dimensioni così con
tanti trofei un disastro adesso lo
faccio perché saranno tutti max ati
tutti i potenti si va dai proviamo
improvvisiamo allora meglio i power up e
cassette qua li sento ok questi qua se
li colpisce riesce molti sì però questi
quando non la fa ce l'ho ce l'ho ma
guarda che devi qua fin qua ci siamo
ricordi sia bello della sopravvivenza e
che qui power up riesce a compensare la
differenza di livello nel senso che se
tu arrivi a 10 15 povera diventi come un
broker normale tanto
ok ok ok giudicato assai 4.000 di vita
diciamo che alla fine questa modalità è
forse la migliore per giocare con
livelli più bassi
certo siamo a 4 guarda se cominciamo
quella win far impazzisco e noi ci
speriamo
io ci spero veramente un sacco perché
purtroppo non ne vico spesso braconi gli
ho imparato almeno almeno a non fare
hanno avuto uno che non è abbattuto
guardi troppi ragazzi di fare attenzione
pazzesca nessuno che pensavo della nave
francamente lo coppa tutto sotto
controllo che io vado possenti che umbro
leggenda ragazzo si sente troppo alto
grazie avete rotto
cioè è alto e passa mai di scassato uno
scherzo
io però alzato tenete così non scherza
finisco questa è la basso bisognerebbe
ragazzi stanotte è che vede l'ex l'avete
detto voi e attenzione a iosa ti prego
ok io vivo non so quale continua a
essere vivo tanto da basso ci sta se
qualcuno mi si lamenta lo tengo così
ormai vede rho e niente poi la prima la
prima andata abbiamo in parte frenare
l'audio e plan e dell'audio ok ok ok era
colpa dell'audio va bene pure la
missione però abbassato regala più di
così ho chiara la prossima così a fatemi
concentrare che è difficile dobbiamo
vincerne una gioca ancora diciamo una
sola pronto a ragazzi hanno le 15 e 13
prima di 15 e 40 passiamo barocche cli
ge e proprio vedere come va grazie il
problema non è questo il problema e
dobbiamo vincerne una nel mentre una
allora possiamo fare partiamo con
partiamo con la convinzione di essere i
più forti del perché quello che che ti
frega la fine o che se il forte del
mondo
gli altri demoni solo altri devono solo
fare schifo perché gli atti non sono in
grado di fare mi guarda guarda come
giocano male gli altri si è ficcata cui
ha pensato come venezia gioca così
ragazza se vinciamo veramente king
attenzione foglio a4 power up attenzione
a metà mattina ad un sicuro è arrivato
nel deretano proprio tira bambola 2008
che sto per morire levato sicuro madonna
che botta o magari ecco un po chi safe
colpisce dalla distanza eventualmente
magari facciamo anche qualche change
alla recuperi vita solo se non colpisce
è bravo che mai detto sta roba perché
non quindi hai tempo di riprendere
invece pare colpita pensando di farmi
fuori per caso il problema della rete
che la vetta forma una sorta di scudo
protettivo che gli salva la vita
io c'ho pochissimo life ci prova resiste
lontano in faccia e morto è morto è
morto fanno fallo mi rendi visibile è ok
si è così nemico non è più uguale di
uguale e morto a bordo è morto ce l'ho
fatta bella lì per dire che siamo stessi
occhi oggi dice ok se preso in faccia e
cosa sapete cari all'altra madonna
regala sto sognando l'abbiamo fatta una
allora incredibile
la cosa bella è che questa è la moto
perfetta il bombardino nel settimanale
ma i fatti non è e non è male cioè mi
sta distruggendo attenzione attenzione
vedete ragazzi chi è pro player problemi
in tutti i giochi senza chiudere se
fortunati che hanno portato fortuna alla
roma io voglio cuffa dopo magari ne
parliamo per provincia non ho sbagliato
mi sono mi sono voltato il fascio
sbagliato tutto scusate lo avevamo
sbagliato tasto ma john stamos i fermi e
l'ho detto la prima di riscaldamento
prego no alla seconda solo esse
invisibile può colpire anche sopra che
ci sta uno sull'erbetta quelle ma poi ci
stavano sono i due allora non vincerò
mai ma per sono morto ciao sono porto
peccato peccato del caso del caso per
caso terza potenziato mercato sapendo
stiamo capendo canova non è male è come
comizio per per non aver mai giocato
contro 20
dai dai dai dai dai tantissimo
per forza regale importante vederci
vincere anche solo una partita
allora consigli al volo tipo
impegniamoci di più la facciamo
secondo me sì è vero che siamo tanto
ceco faccio ugualmente asca vittorio
perché ceco che sia tutto ok però
tranquilli questo ritengo bombardino
bombardiere molto buono venga deve
cambiare potente senza problemi dopo 6
su rocket league non ne vinciamo una
osano che doveva vincere tutte perché
rock etnica è più facile comunque
secondo me però variare di più
diciamo che qua ci sono 26 team 6 contro
1 miliardo di persone controllo che non
solo che ci sono due team quindi
effettivamente 50 per cento sempre tu
dovresti fare sia la fase offensiva che
difensiva perché io andrò in giro
sistema sei tranquillo tasti farò segnò
l'obiettivo sarà fare segnare te non ti
pago anche l'assist di parola se stai
tranquillo che non segni lavorare non ci
consideriamo anche la crociera allora
mister polar che deve partire subito
quel demonio ma va fatto un mazzo tanto
adesso che ha preso si aspetta ma
quest'anno ma sono partiti a 8 questi
fanno chiari che si avevano fatto una
kill ce la stiamo giocando sulle 0
scorso lele 0 coop perché a tre squadre
in una parola
occhio che stonano qua 14 mila mamma mia
che male che ti farà non mi ha fatto
altro vasca ero come faccio ero ovunque
a verona abbiamo ancora mezz'ora per
vincere una partita ce la potremo fare
sulla fascia di bonaccia ci siamo in
mezzo 0 coppe se riusciamo sempre
mettersi va bene ok siamo scemi momento
no che sì ma hanno fatto tutto loro ci
sono pallini hanno canto sul tema e la
cosa bella è che ti considera partita
vinta anche se fa la seconda posizione
c'è chi dà comunque le cose a ok ok ok
va bene ma noi dobbiamo arrivare prima a
me non me ne frega niente nel secondo
noi almeno una volta primi però tifo in
chat ci serve il tipico dei ragazzi
dovete e ogni volta che perdiamo f in
chat e mi raccomando importante
secondo me è quello che fa ben giro c'è
sull mortis quello che vedeva
sott'occhio che aspetta noi dobbiamo
solamente prendere lavorato perché sono
prendiamo ora possiamo nulli ok ok
andava da pia casa per me ne fanno ma
l'avevano doppia
spero che questo non c'è buscema che io
parlo con qualcuno che il romano vien da
dire pia occhio occhio occhi occhi occhi
occhio ma sono vivo con uno spunto non
so neanche come si guarda te che lo
riceva il movimento inside sai te né
senza cielo dentro e nascosto non si sta
vedendo belle giocate avrebbero male ma
che siano molto più energie tutto per
formentera rimasto solo fede occhio mi
dissocio mi dissocio
uscito dal titolo dall armadio
so benissimo timpano sull'operato nora
gx scaffale dove non puoi mari cono che
si chiama scaffale perdonami se ti
chiami scaffale non puoi uccidere
nessuno io considero per un tot di tempo
mi sono chiamato termosifone gx allora è
già meglio scappare da un trend si
notano comodino esatto che le cose credo
che si sta pure cx rumori ma si stanno
alleando tutti quanti non ho capito se
la gente spin off al the blade significa
che vuole ti in mare ora spero sta roba
esatto se tu spini cosca fare scappare
prevented giocherà con noi
ok e ludico si stanzino valvole farà
kill
io ho tirato una roba sofia a perché è
buono l'attenzione sui ragazzi spara
forte provato gli il compito molto amati
dino guarda che peccato scaffale non ci
provava scaffale non c'è non fare lo smi
c'e piu giusta e restiamo attenzione e
scontro finale con loro ci sono anch'io
scaffali
ecco ho preso le monete è in albergo
come era che io ciò il fumo addosso che
faccio ciò che mi 13 il fumo ed amy è
morta fp di altri o per una volta
madonna lega siamo gx scaffale per
grazie a scaffale che è rimasto fermo è
stato reso onore al suo nome è rimasto
come uno scaffale e abbiamo vinto è
stata è stata incredibile non valutiamo
grondante possiamo fondare un team
competitivo
allora siamo incompleti è il perfetto
perché giustamente siamo nella virtù
all'arena di anche di essere quindi oggi
oggi siamo competitivi al massimo vi di
oggi campioni mondiali
la cosa bella è che si sposa
perfettamente quella milano newsweek
perché proprio questa settimana ci
saranno le finalissime delle bugie e la
scuola con champioship il campionato
quello più longevo d'italia gli sport mi
raccomando ragazzi stamani alle
competizioni perché sarebbero stars
royale e anche noi counter strike e mi
sembra si ma vanno chiamato a metano o
attese quando mesi vediamo adesso mi
guardava mail capito
vai vai là il team e grax fa vga e ci
portiamo quali è successa una roba molto
strana adesso mi mira molto molto molto
diversamente da prima
quindi non so che cacchio mi è successo
adesso poi deserto la faccenda c'è una
fregata la mira non solo non so come mai
però aveva da questa la vedo veramente
difficile anche questa ormai la vittoria
sopra vittoria si è quindi tranquilli al
tranquillizziamoci vediamo se riesco a
esistere
vai cracks grande craxi bella bella
bella bella bella bella o qui striscia
mi guardano sono sciolto però è il
problema è che questo è proprio la mappa
fatto apposta per bombardino
così mino quella ciò che avete maledetti
di fuga dai capelli grazie scaffale
comunque scarse villa ancora che secondo
un passato per te e allora niente lui
non posso sposare ci hanno puntato
ragazzi stasera di stato alla famiglia
era un attimo se ho fatto qualche danno
vai famiglia mi fa così famiglie abbiamo
lavoro possiamo farlo o poi devo
rientrare alla squadra no ma sa che
entro cui che sia un altro amico scatola
fammi uscire nasce dal team già fa mi
uscì un attimo proprio perché riavvio
che ho avuto paura che si siano fregati
i comandi ad ok storia via grande
ragazza comunque una partita l'abbiamo
già vinta e importante è questo
l'importante è questo il gioco si
rifiuta di sta mettendo in difficoltà
adesso si allei all obiettivo già
raggiunto però va bene possiamo vincere
un'altra nel frattempo secondo me si
sono messi male abbiamo ancora una
ventina di minuti quindi secondo me
ancora un'altra vinciamo costo brolo me
la gioco non metto altri perché gli
altri ce l'ho ancora più alti quindi
fanno ancora più danni
ed è per forza non ha certo rimane
magari vuoi cambiare vuoi provare ma
allora se tu mi dici che questo qua è
utile per la mappa che c'è adesso aiuti
continuo di disarmo un bambino se mi
dice che è di 189
a me piace perché anche su overwatch
quando i periodi cui giochiamo un sacco
di giocatori
brighi nakadate che variamente lanciare
bombe
io lancio l'onda caso ammazzavo
lanciando bombe a caso e quindi stessa
roba dovunque vado anche solo che trig
lancio di bombe che non ci sono e vinco
quindi e questo proposito facciamo così
ragazzi vediamo se mia fixato lei
missino si è fissato a 6 ottimo quindi
momenti di panico che siamo più perché
lanciati ma chi è che lancia ste bombe
così che milan fastidio il ragazzo fatto
la trazione prima fila rai grazie allora
finalmente nati in città il missile in
faccia per sé sia proprio avere degli
amici in game
allora strings schneider atc e fatevi
uccidere per favore che così prendiamo
pure ringraziamo importante di nuovo ma
in realtà
in realtà tutti i pro player fanno così
e solo che non lo non ho capito è vero
non lo dicono e quello che c'era anche a
me succede è la quarta sala già nei
missili che non ho paura non ho però io
voglio che sia agito per favore la
voglia di gxt praticamente superstar ci
sono solo i tuoi occhi oggi giochi
occhio allora diciamo che siamo
veramente tanti gx per questo siamo
diventati un bel e c'è chi ci odia chi
c'è a roma siamo veramente botto ma ecco
i vincitori sono sempre così e penso che
vuole chi le ha ma è giusto così io non
so se colpirne uno mi dispiace ci sono
per giocare tranquillo dovunque ciò che
ci serve qualcuno che ti segue quindi ci
dispiace ucciderlo dall'aquila pira per
avanzare richiedibile quel signore lì
non ricevono grande g die che ci proprio
da roma che però va bene è tutto rega
snipe c'è una persona che gioca a bruce
normalmente
si è potuto dire ci seguono siamo noi a
tenere superstars praticamente ai nonché
figlio se non vi fidate non vi e picchio
guardiamoci guardiamo ce ne pare
non capisco se un amico oppure no però
c'è sardano mai che sicuramente nord
anomalia è infatti arrivato io non ho
toccato niente per sicurezza ho detto
voglio farmi amici invece mi hanno
sciolta niente a nessuno ebbene proprio
99 next one
bye bye bye ai ragazzi almeno un'altra
wind sarebbe top farne tv 3 si no certo
33 pri e manca un quarto d'ora
vediamo speriamo io ci sto per carità
intanto grazie anche al card michele
fabbri e capri kaymer grazie mille
ragazzi libere non prendere paura verdi
perché subito con fave lampada andiamo
direttamente su ok tu è quello
stranamente italiano non me lo aspettavo
che ci fosse un italiano esatto
aspettavano conte permette g
emma non è morto che anche se l'ho
colpito gli atti a fuggire
ok vai via via arriva il paladino fede
manila perfetto e invece mi ha colpito
sto maledetto modo faccio l'in ragazzi
sono concentratissimo ecco mi è tornato
c'è uno che sta per morire quello che
vuole non lo so hanno colpito lo sto
colpendo si è morto non è morto perché
io levo niente purtroppo il mio
personaggio fa schifo lega non è
leone upgrade ato neanche per sbaglio
l'ho ucciso porto non lo uccido no no
adesso si no ci ha pensato le donne leo
mi mangio io vi ha mangiato occhio ci
stava un one rc studi di 35 ancora
cinque stati rimaste ma sono morti in
2000 come marie nascono quindi c'è
bisogno che la rari tutti e due per
togliere un team
se invece nei kg 1 del team con la
farina nascere o certo sinoira per dire
possibile che nessun team è stato uno
sono svegli questa è la bella l'ho
colpito con i predict recupera vita che
adesso ci servono di fermo vorrei
assassinare l'assassino però non è
semplice c'è l'ha visto l'acqua questo
qua cosa vuol dire avere il super libri
per esempio che nonno che va bene
guardo no ma c'è gente come possiamo
vincere ci senta chiedere leggi
difficilissimo te lo dico professiamo
fare seconda posizione possiamo fare
questo amico mio olio andato in faccia
però nella vita niente dietro c'è gente
sia morti ci riesci per l'altro non ci
credo vai vai vai vai vai resi coletto
serie no oggi 1 da tre ma tranquillo
vedrà quello ff lasciate sempre un f
continua regala con ragazzi che
arriviamo familiari a temi cari a temi
attenzione eccovi paperella togliere
bonifica e che fanno proprio niente ridi
ridi anche qui dobbiamo rimanere un
attimo sopra e loro se devono colpire
praticamente è infatti però a me
arrivano cose che dovrebbe essere creato
una seconda esatto tensione secondo
posto né ma abbiamo preso un po dico per
me non sa più se l'attenzione adesso
diamo non superiamo vediamo un attimo
400 altre 95 esaminano qualcosa di uno
schiaffone da noi prova a vedere sul
cammino e ci metto tre anni attorno
indietro 500 dovresti sbloccati niente
beckham 500.000 una coppa da è di bronzo
lei anzi di legno che fai schifo ma non
vogliamo il rocchetto tutto ff in cioè
la chat è perfetto grazie per gli f però
ragazzi l'impegno c'è l'impegno c'è
ragazzi ricordiamo che con vodafone
power claiming i giochi come blue stars
ma anche tutti i giochi da sopra sel e
anche altri sono assolutamente frigi
ganso giocarli è totalmente free ragazzi
ma formativi
c'è poi sul sito c'è tutta quanta la
lista se non erro c'è anche i pokémon
voce asphalt c'è stato un sacco di
saluto di nuova esatto e noi oggi
terremo samir non lo tocchiamo la diamo
noi tocchiamo non tocchiamo allora
vogliamo gx fa vj e va bene come se
cambia lo metto subito di avere il
cambio nickname
gratis va bene promettiamo gx troppo e
tu cosa fai metti fj craxi grazie al
casinò diventiamo se una sinergia io sta
ammassando gente che non me ne frega
nulla
mi avvicino avvenendo occasione uno
vicino sono il migliore associato
basta con il top c'è anche il doppio ma
proprio da prendere di mela rischio
perché troppo bene rischia di altezza
riguarda la un po demodé monili e dj
brilla io comunque ragazzi sono
veramente senza parole
cioè si muove bene gli stilisti
guardavamo i mari all'inizio non ero
così è stato questa difficoltà uno di
vita 118 è morto otto e c'è gente però
che fastidio c'è la gente 18 che voleva
andare a prendere le gemme ma no mamma
hanno tappato la via occhio occhio che
c'è uno qua questo quale trofei ma cosa
vuoi ma mantenerci fuori e script arci
le 500 coppe
dobbiamo fare le 500 coppe assolutamente
ok questo è buono senato gadget in tre
tutor far giocare a matera che voltatosi
però non so se è servito a qualcosa no
occhio questo qua è a 7 c fa fuori come
niente
attenzione attenzione però guarda lì che
rimasto a mille
peccato che il creato il caso attenzione
sta alla sala siamo invisibili
totalmente entriamo mai mai mai però
pure la poca vita se ci aiuta a samir e
quell'energia di dubai samir la puoi
dirlo forte samir io sto cercando di
distruggere con una che stavolta sotto
aspetta che cesta questo che c'è niente
ero che non so come è morto non è morto
non muore sala dobbiamo il boom è morto
che cosa ti faccia cessa mia famiglia e
morì ti prego fai è più forte di me
ragazzi va benissimo mi sono stato nei
piedi per riuscire a fare questa corato
dove dovresti aver sbloccato credo jesse
come si legge sul cammino in alto a
sinistra che prendi e sblocca gesti o la
gessi bravo il cammino di trofei il
fucile energetico
però in questo caso non mi serve no no
qui allora vediamo ora abbiamo vinto
allora mancano 10 minuti poi switch amo
su rocket league ma se ne diciamo ancora
un'altra mia vita e tre sono arrivati i
primi inter partite quindi importante
non ne vorrà una dieci minuti per ancora
una partita ragazzi grazie mille
blackfire per il web
diciamo che siamo tantissimi non oso
immaginare quello che succederà solo le
righe ma il like ragazzi e cell
apprezzamente la streaming grazie
ragazzi apprezzate last reaming perché
ci stiamo impegnando un sacco bongrazio
venuto qua a soffrire col buon favi
perché io l'ho facendo soffrire ma in
realtà pensavo molto peggiore motivata
bella gara meno male meno male poi
ovviamente ringraziamo chi ci sniper a
quello certo occhiello tolto buono che
ancora una ragazzina mi ha ancora una si
sa questo qua mista caricarci a 4
ce l'ho anch'io però a me fanno sempre
paura quelli che hanno un sacco di vita
novità soprattutto contro bombardino
sono molto utili e non c'è però la bosso
è sì se qualcuno che arriva addosso sono
disintegrati marco
sono cari un muro distrutto quello c'è
qualcosa che di colpi cari niguarda
siamo 5 ok siamo anche rischiarsi il
paura quanto sopra non ce l'ha ma guarda
anche questa potrebbe essere una wind ma
se si usa notte in se resta la gente ci
ha messo le mine ne stanno una ok l'ho
distrutto preso all'inizio che se arriva
uno se la gente a destra centrodestra
indebolisco questa è la copia morto la
coppia si sia voluto era naruto la
verifica di questa leon
se ci andiamo se come la facciamo perché
siamo in due dal demonio
vieni sopra lega lo chiediamo vai bravo
a c'era pure il barry il fortunale
ragazzi non so non so chi in target aree
perché sono tutte e due un sacco da un
sacco di da occhio che sta venendo qua è
rimasto niente al riguardo è morto e
potrebbe dare si resiste resiste basta
pgm fi piace mi fai in realtà di aspetto
così ferocemente io che anche anche che
speriamo nei modi con gli occhi oggi non
c'e new zealand e se qua sotto
questa ultima di far recuperare vita
anzi andrà a morire probabilmente morto
a questo 27 dicembre morto è morto
arrivo loro arrivo io son tre gemme
faccio schifo non madonna scontro finale
ti prego se 13 qua c'è gente c'è gente
qua ti prego resisti 76 53 bene hai
fatto tu riporterà solo bravissimo mamma
mia mamma mia
mamma mia ragazzi pazze non so che dirvi
ma un fenomeno bravissimo meraviglioso
allora 3 qui l'abbiamo fatta e adesso
cominciare due missioni e da fare
sarebbero se le vinciamo un'altra aula e
commissioni per il pass
ok va bene adesso ci il le tre vittorie
di obiettivo l'abbiamo fatto e quindi
per gli ultimi dieci minuti prima di
passare a rocket league giochiamoci il
ci facciamo adesso possiamo anche
lasciarlo agli altri tranquillo adesso
lascia maglia quindi se perdiamo
l'abbiamo voluta perdere la gara è
tratto fra la corvo atene ha offerto
mamma mia che partire la grana ragazzi
sono veramente troppo contento grazie
grazie di essere morti per la causa che
visse sacrificati senza criticati dalla
live c'è uno si chiama arden kakà va
bene buono non mi sembra fantastici
non temete che sia valori per non
uccidere ti prego venuta il mio nome
animata si accennava volta separato da
sparato dal km io non sarà questo in
aree non sai come fai devi girare
velocemente grave l attenzione
loria ori note toccherò non quello che
io voglio
qua c'è un tizio si ma a me sciolgono
ormai queste una partitaccia mi suicido
mi butto nel fumo li faceva il team da
sotto non ho il fumo capitolo almeno
prima fra l'asse mediano per qualunque
sono fino a certo cento su punti
secondo una mia il calcolatore no niente
e probabilmente questo agli aerei nato
che sfila fatto da fatto bene fa niente
fa interni alla sera 2 f e finch atef in
chat ragazzi favore ancora ne facevo
ancora tre le partite le ultime tre
partite e abbiamo fatto
vai lavoriamo andiamo anche dopo
rispondiamo un po di domande e passiamo
al rocket league lega va bene vi ricordo
per l'ennesima volta che si fosse
connesso adesso diciamo la von pauer
gaming che è un'offerta che può
permettermi di giocare a giochi anche
dico questo senza sprechi giga quindi in
modo la vostra connessione
e io so che tanti ci giocano per tanto
tempo e non c'è importante ma infatti
non lo faccio anch'io spetta vedremo
fuori molto di più ragazzi sui bruciarsi
preparatevi a quello sicuramente se
giochiamo insieme ma io baba anche
domani virtus a sei bravissimo mi piace
un sacco
sei molto più forte di chi parla no sto
scherzando mi chiedono lenti voglio bene
scherza io non capisco niente lo
abbraccia alleghe
ma io sono scarsissimo realtà quelli
veramente forti stanno solo voto con
championship quelli spaccano di brutto a
me non sai che mi hanno chiamato a me
arrivata una mail a destra l'ho visto
con la coda dell'occhio mentre stavo
facendo prima abbiamo perso perché legge
o la mail di haslem se voglio
partecipare al torneo mondiale con
questo scempio non livellato centro con
questo bravo le hanno livellato fontanot
occhio comunque lombardia una questione
di predict e alla festa tutto previsto
infatti se broker meno utilizzati perché
la gente va dritto coi colpi e alla
lontana e un po com'ero gli amici a
doveri sono un po difficili ok però sono
gran figo che chi il bravo sì bravo si
aspetta le prove delle nel circuito
cesta nessuno ok no siamo andati suoi
hacker ma noi lo faremo fuori lo stesso
cesta quella con l'ombrellino che fa
male forte meglio di culto addosso diamo
morta norta perfetto scontro finale
attenzione chi rimasto eco omar si io vi
giuro mi sarei mai aspettato di far
ripartire nikiniki e nicky e nicky è
morto 44 madonna tutti per spacciati 2.0
che partite scalando che tra cancello
credibile incredibile in che ne sono
contentissimo sono contentissimo
va beh intanto è infatti sta scalando
coppe con col favi ragazzi che volete ma
abbiamo una differenza di 500 copie però
però comunque stiamo scalando ci crede
troppo proroga troppo pro basta basta
così dare prova di questo basta
aveva mandato una mail a posto comunque
hai fatto l'ultima l'abbiamo fatta
favole utile 2 scusate dal 32 32 ok
quindi questa è un'altra
siamo a 40 vittorie io volevo farne uno
all'inizio arrivato a quattro quindi
dire che ottimo qua ci stanno le gemme
per questo mi ha criticato che arriva
quello con la pala quello cattivo
ok quello che l'apparecchio attivo
immagina che attacchi avvisano di 60
avvicinata ed esalto vede cercherò di
far certi con la pala
no quello che rallenta ahia ahia mouth
che sotto nelle prime ma io come faccio
a milano mi stanno preparando tutti è
finito beh non posso fare niente ne
hanno ostacolato il 26 anche il campione
del mondo questa partita è così male
male male l'ultima l'ultima sarà
l'ultimo sarà quella giusta ricomprese
le passerà gale aprirò dopo perché mi
sono concentrati in questo momento the
last one e poi passiamo a rocket league
quindi quello che farò non si
preoccupare amico io non ti preoccupare
faremmo forse anche una classifica molto
il tutorial è praticamente ho scelto la
macchina quella arancione tipo stile la
corsa carriera va ventre ma non ho mai
quella base che quella standard quella
che usano tutti anche i problemi fantab
che ho fatto perché a light box più
giusta ma in realtà i nostri livelli
anche al mio
chissenefrega ho visto tipo c'era il
furgoncino oppure quella tuttavia non ti
preoccupare va bene così un po di guar
descritto sbagliato attenzione tenta
l'attacco ma non c'è niente halloween
sei fuori stagione via via parigi craxi
la coppia dell'anno ma ragazzi ma
infatti dobbiamo farlo molto prima cioè
non sono esatte o forza l'uomo è l'unico
problema di bombardino secondo me è che
arriva di una polente ste bombe se
fossero un po più veloci io sarei
veramente
sarebbe un altro colpo lauer libro sta
to devi essere bravo a colpirli in
predict perché poi la bozza non solo fa
danno da capa tanta lo sapeva non avevo
idea quindi non era vero il mercato
neanche male detto nichi ma perché non
fa matanic installato no no no no no no
no no no no peccato non esce arrivando 1
dall'alto e stavo rischiato se stiamo
insieme possiamo provare a chiudere
questa b b ma non è un problema ai
ragazzi il gioco cefali c'e la citta
insegna l'agila bruciarsi credibile
arriva nella sua opera è andato
l'attenzione quello andato o siamo siamo
invisibili perfetto deliziato chiunque
si sia effettivamente quella sì ricevuti
sei bravo ok io dico sempre molta
attenzione che dimostra niente colori
però io devo dirgli un po così bravo
siamo ancora quattro team non è semplice
ragazzo potrebbe andare giù cieli leon
anche perché la sopra tori
carnevalissimo ragazza e combattuta e mi
piace mi piace come ultima e combattuta
il bomber o fisici professore fare
giocare un po tattiche vediamo se
entrano sicuro ma ci provo
perché scegliere secondo bravo aspetta
insomma brecker joe era uno rinascita
dopo rapper dai ragazzi e l'abbiamo
chiudere moorman assolutamente procedure
delle ong che quello che il cappuccio
ultimi l'ho fatta sono stati mollato
eccola andata
così così si gioca così si gioca
maledizione così si gioca male mamma mia
come lanciano questi ragazzi ma come mi
fai sognare che uomo che uomo vodafone
smart challenge
eccoci qua ragazzi 2.0 ditemi se non
volete terza poi dopo questo ditemelo è
e ditemelo
mammamia regalò la mamma mia come
chiudono come chiudono per riprenderci
90 talk fa un pò llama basta ragazzi
abbiamo chiuso così la le partite di
brown star
adesso passiamo a rocket league ma prima
un attimo di cillo che mi devo
riprendere in un sogno che come sia
possibile quindi leggiamo le domande che
ci avete fatto va un attimo di cillo
intanto chiamate i vostri friends di
piacere che ti che adesso facciamo una
bella partita col buon grax e vediamo un
po allora ero già il gioco allora urlerò
abbastanza devi stare tranquillo però ti
porterò all'olimpico speriamo allora
ragazzi andiamo sul profilo boda phone
io vado sul profilo vodafone che mi
avete fatto le domande lim tanto i suoi
limiti di tempo dei social perché ci
sono gli sparo le immagini
allora sì però io mi do anche la
sembra la scusa che per lavorano e per
lavoro potrei fare vabbè quando la
domanda affari j grazxie risponderemo
dante alle diventa allora anche io la
faccio ma come avete fatto a vincere
cinque volte ho fatta questa qua ho
fatto anch'io sul profilo di moda fa un
perfetto perché non sapete che se la
passano allora in questo momento allora
le domande dovevano ritrova dovrebbero
arrivarci le domande dovrebbero
arrivarci la domanda io non le sono
arrivate dalla madre perfetta
ok allora prima domanda di two day my
friends se non avessi fatto youtuber che
cosa avreste fatto vari spolitu caro a
questa è una domanda un po particolare
per me perché la cosa bella è che io in
questo momento non so se lo sai fa vi
avevo raccontato cioè io sono un chimico
nel senso facendo bottino di reti per
dire un barista però sa bene ovvio che
le buttiamo alla i barman è un po un
chimico alla fine è vero hai ragione
spiega il villino diciamo ragazzi e ho
iniziato a fare lo youtuber mentre sto
facendo il mio percorso di vita standard
cia da lavoratore come chimico quindi al
momento ancora io non so che cosa sono
cioè sono né carne né pesce 61 youtuber
kim bellissimi favi che avresti fatto
schifo
quando ho iniziato a fare
il liceo ne ho preso inizio informatico
perché mi piaceva il computer poi però
voti quattro video detto beh forse non è
quello giusto
e poi mi è andato bene che ho conosciuto
nichi il ragazzo che abbiamo citato di
fama torna live per nostro scherza
comunque nichi ma è veramente forte
abbronzarsi in realtà sto scherzando era
per scherzo perché nel caso non lo
sappiate è con lui abbiamo aperto il
canale gaming però io credo che a questo
punto avrei lavorato sempre nel mondo
nei computer in qualche modo frase
dietro le quinte ma sempre nel montaggio
video volo pazzesco cioè abbiamo la
stessa storia anche aperto un canale
all'inizio in due se vengo se ho
cambiato nome perché il medico ma
lasciato tra virgolette non riuscivo a
ma dai
ho cambiato il nome in grecia e dal
libro sposo esploso molto simile è molto
simile molto simile al tasse
cosa avete pensato quando state facendo
questo primo video è abbastanza
imbarazzante pensano che sia
imbarazzante un po per tutti all'inizio
la cosa bella è che il mio primo video
ancora c'è online
pane è il modo differente si sente
l'accento ternano è proprio un'altra
cosa è però finita 6 a lei sono di terni
sono in umbria perché è simile a romano
ma infatti sembrava fossero fossi roma
nero convinti che poi ho cambiato molto
diciamo il mio lessico la mia edizione
umbria quindi fico e il mio video ancora
online nel primo video ed è un video
brutto però avevo tanta voglia di
presentare il mio villaggio di cacio
france quindi ho pensato dai voglio
spaccare ma poi ti fai iniziato proprio
così su sto mondo proprio figo tutto
boba ii
qual è l'esperienza migliore che avete
fatto che ha seguito in ma naturalmente
giocare col buon graz e vincere cinque
vittorie in cinque partite in rosa sin
live cioè ragazzi questo è il massimo e
poi ce n'è una tua allora qua ci
chiedono ragazzi bruciarsi è compreso in
vodafone power gaming ha solamente se
abbiamo detto prima lo ricordiamo vola
con power gaming vi consiglio di andare
sul sito dell'offerta c'è una lista
incredibile di giochi ma sono compresi
tutti i giochi supercell quindi nation
plans la jolie alber stars anche gli
altri e dato che ci stiamo tanto tempo
soprattutto che adesso diciamo subito
stars e serve tanto tempo per scalare è
comoda perché non vi fa spendere giga
alfa asfalta nuove c'e anche pokémon
ma quindi c'è anche i clash clash of
clans cresceva pianse altro quindi se tu
avessi fatto quel video con vodafone
padre che si spacca dg che attenzione
secondo queste sono tecniche e
fantastico va bene nel mio questo è per
me nel mio libro quale l'amicizia più
bella tra i personaggi secondo te che
domanda incredibile sante le domande
incredibile mi dovete polito rompere le
ship che si sono create
topi e il protagonista ok così almeno
uno speriamo niente perché se dico altri
personaggi poi un casino però è vero poi
sono stati due di no ha visto tranquillo
melo te lo mangiano anche
ti ringrazio qual è la cosa che mi piace
ma che purtroppo non posso rispondere io
però ragazzi piccolo spoiler prossimo
anno dovrebbe uscire qualcosa di carino
anche mio ok va bene qual è la cosa gli
piace di più dei videogiochi il fatto di
poter giocare insieme ad altre persone
sentirsi parte di una community
oppure il videogioco in sé
allora entrambe nel senso che io quando
gioco a qualcosa
allora dipende c'è stato un periodo va
da periodi ci sono tre lingue gioco
videogames e sulla campagna quindi la
storia principale ci sono in cui gioco
tipo rocket league con i miei amici
quindi gioco per stare in compagnia e
che avevo di videogiochi siano in grado
di valorizzare entrambe queste cose
quindi si vede tra le incredibili allo
stesso tempo giocare tra gli incredibili
ma allo stesso tempo può giocare con gli
amici passano un po di tempo insieme
e tutto molto molto bello e io credo che
i videogiochi abbiamo fatto parte della
tua vita come anche della mia
diciamo che sono due cose che vanno in
parallelo sia l'intrattenimento stesso
del gioco che il fatto di creare una
community
diciamo nel mio contesto superstars
siamo riusciti a creare nei comuni di
pazzesca si sono create delle amicizie
ed è una cosa bellissima
allora ragazzi facciamo neanche
rispondiamo ancora un paio di domande
poi passiamo al rocket league
preparatevi allora il pro di gameplay
più divertente che avete che avete fatto
oddio getting over it è stato molto
formativo molto formativo getting over
it amici miei il tuo volo forse una
delle cose ragazzi che mi sono divertito
di più in assoluto sempre su broshure fu
diciamo ai tempi si poteva fare adesso
non si può fare più giocare con lo
stesso brawler leggendario che era leon
e chi l'harley tutti e tra l'altro il
video co più visual del milan e del
bronzo
ok
quali sono i vostri giochi preferiti
proprio in generale il momento ragazzi
brussels quello che gioco di più poi a
scaletta che la sharia le stanze sono le
porte sul canale e tra l'altro su quelli
della vodafone
sono qui da vodafone paolini che tu sei
a posto la giunta ha salutato che hanno
salvato la vita come no ma è l'offerta
fatta apposta per me per te incredibile
infatti io direi io direi fare una
petizione per chiamarla buona con grassi
naming sono però allora la cosa che
volevo dire è che conduce allo stato
manda è sempre difficile rispondere
perché molti non conoscono visti qui
diversi tipi di giochi magari molti
giocano solo mobile o botti giocano solo
pc e quindi io ho un gioco per ogni
piattaforma che per pc in questo caso è
rocket league e mi piace tantissimo per
mobile ma sai che ti dico la verità che
secondo me brooks e non sto scherzando
proposta è un ottimo candidato perché
non ci gioco molto perché non mi col
tempo ci siamo persi e quindi ci gioca
tanto però non abbiamo mai giocato
insieme negli ultimi anni però abbiamo
iniziato iniziato a giocare insieme
proprio per lo stato e per quello che è
un po come muovermi lo capisco è tra i
giochi mobile te lo giuro che è quello
che mi piace di più veramente qui non
sto scherzando primo bale broll stars
dovrei skill armi molto di più
ovviamente procedevo sceglierne uno
quella il candidato migliore ea livello
di console mettervi a metà gli assoli 9
lo stars è un gioco che ha un potenziale
pazzesco però non lo sfruttano a dovere
se lo possono potenziare ancora di più
speriamo
va bene l'ultima domanda a leggere una
domanda ok ma il team a tours purtroppo
non è arrivato a me parigi aic leila
vedere la patente mi dietro bene quindi
adesso possiamo allora rocket l'ing
però che cli ge e il gioco molto
simpatico dove quindi una macchina caso
io faccio anche nella vita di tutti i
giorni perché io ho la patente
allora questa è la super wag a fare una
macchina super sue bellissime ma in
realtà è questa questa skin animata che
c'è da un sacco di tempo e dalle ruote
lo sbloccate tipo stamattina
allora quando ci sei dimmelo alla 16
sono spetta che ti vedo di video che
divido io ok c'è de vito
allora facciamo una bella cosa ragazzi
secondo me oa portare buon grax che non
ha mai giocato e sta facendo una cosa
molto difficile giocavo la tastiera
mamma rocket l'ignoto la tastiera rocket
league non lo saprei neanche aprire cioè
non so cliccare sull'icona quindi non so
come vero però a ben solido chi gioca
dal pc viene considerato però so che
supportano ai tre giorni no no no sì ma
io gioco sempre a pc però col joypad
perché dopo la tastiera ci sono dei pro
player che giocano con la tastiera e ma
è difficile che ne trovi uno comunque
proviamo innanzitutto in casuale e
vediamo qua con te qua come pro stars e
quindi più giochi contro gente del
livello mio perché mi metta con quelli
quindi sarà un po difficile
vediamo allora importante oggi non è
vincerle tutte ma farti fare gol
ovviamente vincere e fare alcune vincere
e farti fare gol quindi più devi
insegnare allora la prima del fai e
caricare la palla carica non così
attenzione non credo che questo subito
dopo che diciamo tutti il tag su tutti i
problemi erano è la verità che non c è
non si va da nessuna parte allora tu ti
muovi quindi sai come ci si muove
sì più o meno però e sai che ti farà
capire in avanti per andare più veloce
no questo non sapevo ok allora guardami
guardami l'attimo guarda arrivo arrivo
beni questa caprio lago fatto sarebbe
spinge la palla avanti
mammamia quello di difesa fa tranquillo
tranquillo
normale è normale ok per me questo punto
non devi volare non ti preoccupare non
c'è bisogno che l'ho fatto lo faccio ora
bravo bravo va bene non ti preoccupare
l'importante è farlo
il momento giusto e ci arriverà il
momento attenzione questi li ho fatti
fuori ed è gol
ed e cosi delle cose nome non bellissimo
ma tu mi chiama favignana perché molti
mi pagano sempre nella città quindi dice
voi avete tutte le macchine bellissimo
io praticamente dice un giocattolo dotti
preoccupare caro l'importante è che lì e
dobbiamo farti fare gol e lo farai per
far fare con la grazie con dome ragazzi
dobbiamo fare una cosa dobbiamo
stancarci di punteggio perché se non per
fare perché quel problema sai quale
diversamente da proposta se qua tu ti
perdi anche solo una cosa
un'azione e fanno con gli altri quindi
ogni ogni singolo secondo la partita
importante si può distrarre un attimo ha
mai fatto bene fatto bene solo che
quest'anno ripartendo forse non si va
avanti
si va avanti ma in mezzo e mezzo busto
primavera dai talk e non potevo mettere
la violenta dai dai dai non ti
preoccupare non ti preoccupare non ti ma
quanto sei forte fa anche se non a
questi so scarponi ok c'è secondo me voi
non so in realtà solo del livello mio
però in realtà sono di rango più alto
del livello in cui sono perché ci sono
due tipi di val d'isère anche con il
livello livello cioè quante partite hai
giocato eccetera quindi io che sono
giocato un po differenti regione è
un'ipotesi di questo ha voglia
io ho giocato anche con il campione
italiano è uno dei campioni del mondo è
stato
eccola
allora siamo 30 quindi se facciamo un
altro gol e questi non abbandonano che
spera che non abbandoni posso mettere
the line oppure giochiamo già allora
facciamo così
sti cavoli giochiamo già per far segnare
grax occhiali adesso provo carter ha in
mezzo al momento trick vai tu vai vai
carica no fatto nardiello barack obama
non ti preoccupare a trovare ok ecco
ecco sei lì stylist ai listelli filati
fidati di me mi sono bloccato vado solo
retromarce fidati di me no sei fermo a
te impazzito il gioco di successo versi
c'è nel senso tipo ah ok è corta che
sbagliava la più elevata
tutto regolare e tranquilli tranquilli
perfetto va avanti migranti garanti
all'aiuto e mezzo mamma mia l'ho toccata
piano d'arte la stai sempre in mezzo
bravo bravo sacra o un peccato sta in
mezzo sta in mezzo aiuterà minute la
battuta dovresti so poi toccare capito
mi stai proprio in mezzo non solo
deviare in porta
vai vai carica caricato un vetro vai
oddio è stato purtroppo out c'è quello
che produceva belo schivata risorto
intanto prende un po del busto perché se
non è stato mai tirati a mamma mia che
il rischio io sto giocando solo che
fanno segnare lega e edificio la faremo
ce la faremo
importante e questo è incredibile che
non fa niente lo fa niente per il culo
ma da valerio liscio che io ho fatto la
palla aspetta aspetta dai validi che se
in mezzo
no c'era quando in difesa se non ci
fosse stato bene non ce la farei mai
togliere questa è trovato peccato se non
ci fosse stato quello in difesa avresti
segnato te mamma mia
c'eravamo e celeri e certi 6 c 6 c 6 c o
ancora due minuti si può fare c 6 c 6 c
ci sei fammi sognare marvel come va il
momento il momento c'è mi anticipa la
palla su palla detta aspetta aspetta per
divertentissimo regalo bellissimo se
stai in mezzo
eccola per te e tutta tua tira no no no
no le disse a me io mi sono
disinteressato al giorno 100.9 sfiga
ceri però che peccato omaggino alla
frustrazione assist per farlo basta
soprattutto tranquillo tran pfff ma ce
la faremo
ce la faremo ce la faremo a consegnare
sei fermo adesso ok ok però io e mezzo
che mi sono davvero neanche quattro no a
parte che non serve a niente quando
rinnamorare non puoi fare nulla in gioco
è troppo istantaneo ma chi ha amato che
gli staff a mamma mia
quella è una bella palla contesa ah ok
c'è pure il raggio sotto questo l'ho
capita adesso
ok è rimasta dalle labbra occhio che ti
scavalcano infatti aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
proprio le distanze giuste
mamma mia mamma mia insomma 80 che tolgo
tutte fenomeno ripartiamo la vediamo se
di sicuro da arriva mi frega se no beh
però continua qua pensione con la gola
grazie se lippi mi chiama estero
buonissima ma che sfiga io cosa in giro
spassarmela nokia questo pattinerà
fortissimo e non la posso prendere uno
turbo traversa un pallone da sotto non
possibile da ace roncero peccato non
avevo intuito per fare dai lanciatori
centrarla certo segnare il goal darvi
mai allora provo è nostra mamma mia
sarebbe stupendo
non so prova prova a vincerla o a farti
segnare no no vinciamo vinciamo e magari
adesso non
c'è dipende adesso infatti aperte
sbagliato e che io ero e roero
svantaggio ma vediamo se riesco a
rendermi un minimo utile o no è messo in
mezzo a loro e fatto il progetto che
bravo da tirar tira
sono pazzi mamma mia che rischio hanno
rischiato peccato che stavolta ero ci
sta ci sta abbiamo perso ma ci sta
perché non hanno tolto invece non abbia
ancora perso non abbia ancora bene se
questo motivo credo queste cose in gol
prima che segna veramente la tensione
fare per l'onore di brown
devo farlo tranquillo tanto c'è ancora
tempo dopo a ok però prendere vada via o
scusami ma vicino del nuovo capito sono
ma ci sta com'è la dissi ok bella bene
l'ho messo avanti line almeno però tempo
proviamo a vedere ma li anticipano si va
a riva arrivare i vari vario si è ma van
pato la difendo no mammamia meno male
che non è toccata finiva dentro me a
doha dovuto schivare anche testato un
casino occhio lei ci stanno spingendo
non riesco ragazzi a prendere il
tempismo
ok ok il momento il momento buono mirati
prego dimmi che ci sentirà nola datome
la dopo me pero convinto la baduel
dovevo tirare
guarda che manco es infatti vediamo
no non va bene non ti preoccupare la
facciamo al progetto che abbia vinto la
mamma mia se segna vite alla fine però
non è male nel mare
che parata bel tiro f per gli avversari
in questo ho fatto 18 punti buono
tranquillo tranquillo non c'è nessun
problema
allora the next one
vediamo se riusciamo allora l'obiettivo
è far segnare due volte è comunque
secondo me ci siamo di risorto carla nel
modo giusto comunque ci sta facendo
contro gente del mio livello un casino è
esatto che bella questa ambientazione in
figlio vi ricordiamo ragazzi che questa
è la vodafone sua picciano lenge 2.0
avevamo già fatto l'altra con power
giocato a cod
e sempre rocket league e invece adesso
stiamo facendo con il buon grex su
rocket league e roadster
se c'è una componente fondamentale che
sono in gioco che porta oggetti sono che
i due ricercati ci costringe ma
importante che è diventato bravo anche
secondo me ci sei e c6 perché hai capito
che ne consegue la palla come io capisco
che si voglia in questo momento ci
potremmo vincerla perché ti lasci un bot
quindi veramente in pazzesco quello che
è quello che ti ha riscontrato a destra
ok niente andato via è più forte di me
sicuramente il buon dato è andato via è
andato via attenzione tiratina se ci sei
io se ci sei peccato un bravo bravo
bravo bravo io prova dirigerti anche se
non ti vedo perché affidare una mera
titolare ti piace bellissimo vi
ricordiamo ragazzi che è l'offerta
vodafone powergen tv permette di giocare
a determinati giochi senza utilizzare i
vostri gfic a cosa molto utile
attenzione agazzi qua non trovano le
labbra vocalisti è bravo guarda che
questa cosa comunque tu eh mi hanno
scavalcato queste cose sono fatto io
sono stato di un pirla nera non è colpa
mia colpa mia comunque tu bravo fi messa
cosa punti ma a bacchettarli col
pressing che secondo me molto importante
così facciamo sbagliare ci sta è secondo
me se tu pressi potrebbe essere una roba
importante perché il pressing fa senta
sempre fastidio ma qualsiasi tipo di
gioco tu faccia power aveva segnato se
non ho capito power ha segnato è mi pare
di sì ma lui non lo aveva fatto una roba
incrinava fatto delle parate a un certo
punto che se ne avremmo perso
no mai aveva è stata una roba pazzesca
una roba da prenotato quest'anno la
pigliano e va benissimo
i miei ragazzi che sto vedendo un gioco
incredibile tranqui tutto giusto
sono stato da chi e grassi davvero b è
merito del fantasmino ma se c'è più
punti prima che fatto un tiro attenzione
ok allora comunque guai a guardarmi in
partenza guardami comparto se poi qua
una volta che arriva l'ultimo turbo
rotolati davanti vedi che comunque
arrivi la parola prende vai vai switch
madonna l'ho vista lì ci ho provato beta
tocca fa niente prima di ritorno bravo
ma l'isola di linosa per me ha provato a
rovesciata le ibrahimovic fosse andato
più forte è loro allora il gioco sta nel
metterla a lato il più possibile
praticare ci provo mercato solo lasciata
e il gioco a tenerla al lato il più
possibile per evitare che gli altri
tirino perché se latini a lato e di luci
lo aspetti la portano un po come il
roadster siculo vuole nel caso è capito
allora ho capito adesso che se vado sui
puntini gialli milano il busto è
perfetta ma la sta portando in testa è
perché volevo fare questa cosa però poi
sono in due quindi non basta bel
pallonetto
mamma mia ma erano i due non dovevo fare
sta roba perché potevo starmene 1 ma
l'altro infatti mi sono stato solo
quello che roberta ci ho pensato dopo
che erano è giustamente in 222 bene si
può recuperare si voglia però prova a
pronta la portata in avanti però ci sta
ci provo devo andare così va benissimo
andava benissimo infatti la caduta li ho
insegnato loro ma non fa niente
o forse no forse no volo ies ha idee
vuoto difesa di craxi ragazzi tutto come
però buona difesa del gran bravissimo
bene bene che toccò bellissimo ragazzi
importante questo allora è un evento vai
tu no no devo andare io devo andare io
le volevo che sono più vicino lontano
ormai vai vai
[Musica]
proprio lui
mamma mia che l'uomo può veramente
grazie 32 kg volevo dire guarda se vai
vai sai cosa è bravissimo sai cosa ti
volevo dire che la partenza molte volte
rimane ferma e quindi se tu l'hai in
corni giusta che segni e quindi hai
segnato
volevo dirtelo e l'hai fatto volevo
dirtelo il mitico glitch di chi fa
quella roba lì bellissimo sei stato
bravissimo di difesa tg c'è un cliché
che tifa segna la partenza in chi fa non
si sapeva campo nota metà campo 9
locativo due passaggi se porta semi gol
appena di fango
non lo sapevo quello di script pensione
funzione tensione e mezzo dal centro
bocchino no no non ho fatto perché a un
certo punto ho detto va in mezzo si
preferiva mente non so se non
conoscendone le rotazioni va in mezzo
quindi ho detto va bene vai vai vai vai
mai dirà no sceglierà di 26 di no ma
devo buttare dentro forza vado le 8 in
italia il massimo il 4 2 molto povero
potere alla li ferma attenzione
importante quello bravo ragazzi ho messo
la spunta sul gol
i ritmi l'importante questo importante
che tu abbia segnato quello è quello che
sentivo a vincerle mamma mia è rimasto
fermo quella rischiato la tensione che
liscio
eccolo 90 fa niente ciò che è l'altra
parte rigori o mi sembra un altro mondo
e vabbè ma hanno campato per niente
niente gol dopo la mancata con ringrazia
e vai grax e tua se già divieto se ci
arrivi non c'ero io era un bagnante lo
fa niente non fa niente una l'estate
perché sono scarsi vai vai vai vai
momento
forse ne sta pure allineare speriamo
proprio che finisce la partita credo
no no no no non c'è un link continuiamo
con i bot ah no se le fanno tutte e due
abbiamo vinto uno solo è stato vice
mandato vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
carica la carica la va bene non ti
preoccupare ma mai la mancata come un
pirla da sei cosa fai tirante ai gas
ho visto delle robe vai tranquillo
attenzione problema va bene e modo e
invece no e non segnano ragazzi la porta
è stregata opportuna il principio non ha
fregato un bot
ecco bravissimo io e te un fenomeno
presso non potevo togliere nulla di
queste cose perché va bene una volta
dobbiamo vedere la distinzione xxx sono
io ho giusto ma vice istituto adesso
carica nel fortissimo va bene e non
avevo proprio per dare a staccarmi però
però il pallonetto è molto buono e non
potevo fare nulla perché ragazzi sto
vedendo lo spettacolo in questo momento
e non potevo starmene al muro così
el'aveva mancata lui poteva anche
lasciarti ma sai ma non arrivava
arrivato anche niente anche dalla giusta
dice ma tu puoi giocare un team
competitivo sicuramente non ho steso
sono chiamate quasi diamante 3
però poi ci sono i champion e poi il
grand champion e poi giochi competitivo
quindi mi manca che verrà due era anche
e mezzo per arrivare a quel livello e
sono tutte le assicuro impossibili vai
vai mai verrai croci procedibile su
youtube
ho segnato io da dalla difesa veli ma
cosa è successo
mamma mia che la roma ha capito che
niente dice visto che ho visto un video
con un botto diviso della partita
assurda non c'ho capito niente veramente
fortissimi cioè con una donna la nobili
quelli in troppo forti non si capisce
niente quando prova a tirare ti prego
no ragazzi griffate sti momento alla mia
che figata
vai di rex e liscia la palla solo
praticamente lo stata arriva fuori tu
riesci a fare bene però non ho fatto gol
questo è il controllo semplicemente
civilmente ha parlato di festini la
palla sul con sul tettuccio e va in giro
capito come la parata random house e
questa è la cosa che io so fare di più
perché ti popolari io non so buono sono
molto più brava fare questa cosa vede
infatti tipo si riesce controlla molto
bene invece a volare non me la cavicchio
per niente perché a volare
devi saper fare determinate cose diciamo
che sono mediocre bacio molto di primio
gameplay su questo guarda che roba che
la fine non è promessi il male queste
palle incollato invece chi vuole
ronaldinho breve se molti si basano
troppo sul volo troppo sull'altro
infatti non vuol dire molte volte
l'importante è sfruttare le reazioni
capito però va bene se no non ha mai lo
è stata attenzione però attenzione che
tu a scegliere demolisco telefoni sco
porta cosa è tua e tutte e due a mamma
mia
vediamo i punti però penso qualche punto
in più ho fatto perché si lava mai
segnato quindi sicuramente avrà altre
150 punti di standard più alto livello
di tv e ha fatto 2 livello 3 il buon
grex o no ragazzi è anche il professor
però stato abbiamo vinto
ci sono una incredibile bravissimo a fi
pronto per ancora un altro vogliamo
programmare un trofeo limitato boa
qualcosa
bravissimo linguaggio molto orgoglioso
ragazzi 1.136 vai tranquillo e
preoccupata è che tanto c'era una sfida
che vi farebbero 1.100 punti mi sono
sbloccato adesso guarda qua siamo in
allenamento così poi sempre nel
frattempo che cerca mai provati l'area
perfetto non siamo più in allenamento ha
subito la partita siamo 4 monkey e un
nome buy
allora adesso dovrei andare io vedi che
sono come si capisce diciamo da chi è
più vicino leader corsi
se sono qui e forti non lo capisci a
meno che non abbiano sotto un
una scritta che dice che hanno vinto
determinati tornei tipo sono uscito ora
è torneo
aoc tipo dei badge esclusivi nei magic
egli chicca kitchen tornasse no no no
allora in questo momento c'è un trofeo
sulla destra quindi forse queste
prendermeli la palla ed ora può essere
poi rimasta ferma il mezzo il pazzo la
nostra importo che non ho scherzato
allora ho segnato io gli ho fatto un
assist che ragazzi guardano volevo
togliere invece voleva guarda cassis ti
ho fatto spetta a me ma lo sci mi sembrò
preciso libro vero e niente potuto già
molto meglio che vai vai vai dai calcoli
vado non ho saltato e tranquillissimo e
buona
e adesso che non se ne centrare però c'è
sempre uno fermo in porta quindi mamma
mia che polo ragazze ebree rischia sono
stare in porta così a perché alla fine
mandi avanti solo uno occhio occhi
occhio la palla sopra non riesco a
vedere la chiama la mamma mia mamma mia
sto facendo ragazzi glielo tolga dalla
propria perché sto perdendo un po di
burro
ok allora aspettato butta in avanti
provaci il bravo padova in mezzo
provando sia in mezzo hindemith se
ancora visti ancora di fila di meta riva
fila di fila di filati fidati di me vai
vai graz stop dopo la destra non è visto
rubare no un'altra porta l'altra fatto
l'assist per così dire occupa mio tolta
il fenomeno è niente non è passato e
sono in due purtroppo è questi giocano
ragazzi dove due formati ma mia mamma
mia per caso e ci abbiamo provato
ti preoccupare stai tu style a perché da
regolatrice con scritto da arriva da
riva è silano l'hanno messa vivere
by proprio la contesto si prospetta
questo che ci onora dimenticarmi però
dico io ma scusami scusami però perché
sei ripeto varedo consegnare perché
stavano due sotto capito hai ragione
però va bene la prima di tutto la
partita quindi è importante vincere poi
dopo ma come fai a spiccare il volo ma
questa allora devi schiacciare è ma
lascia stare i dati in attivino e contro
le leggi della fisica questa cosa
eh no in realtà usi rai per una
proposizione dei razzi dietro è molto
intelligente ma in volta però che anche
alla nasa facciamo così bravo peccato se
l'avessi toccata avesse avuto lo script
del volo di gogo molto figo
aspetta aspetta che era sbagliato io
tutto l'avevo tra p.zza europa mi sono
fatto ok ok ma tifavo i ragazzi ma tanti
fiori che hanno seguito
mammamia gras nostra qui ma di porta
corro gregorio vera ok io mi sono
buttato qualcosa vale davanti giù così
buona ross vendere nati tutti neanche
capitolino
va bene per romeo bampa di tutti 12
trans ha capito niente bene va bene che
non doveva grande come fai a fare titola
mio sarto noto esatto non è il salto è
quello che cuce salto dice devi
schiacciate volte i ragazzi ed i vincoli
alle 20 in avanti fa la spinta in avanti
che non mi ricordo mai come si chiamano
ma chi se ne frega
attenzione il controllo vado a prendere
turbo mela sposta in avanti la palla in
mezzo potrebbe essere buona per il buon
grazie se li attenzione ora è la lunga
lunga
era impossibile non provare qualcosa
sulla palla sempre nel mezzo attenzione
grazie però a spingerla incredibile
prova liscio e pista gli avversari ho
tentato un chilo bruttissimo la palla
rimbalza adesso segna a loro per forza
che non sono potrebbe essere una
strategia del senso loro che pensano che
io sia forte allora vai bene ma è sempre
così come lo stop all esatto fai bene
tg1 tensioni se ci si potrebbe essere
gol peccato molto bravo l'arrivo gruppo
di buste
peccato è cosa vedo a cosa vedo una
cimice bellissimo non ho visto che offre
successo non ho visto ti giuro che non
l'ho visto fa vedere guarda come arriva
sì ma sei pazzo ma che gol
lei ha anticipato da bravissimo non
l'avevo neanche messa e stava andando
dall'altra parte proprio non s'ha stop
mi stavo disintegra vivissimo mag rex
cela il gol del 3 2
brave e se è vero tu hai sempre tra due
pazzesco pazze ragazzi ma che gioca oggi
veramente asmar challenge del secolo
mamma mia ma come stia cambiando le
partite se questi sono i miei livello e
l'avrebbero una palla e tira va bene non
ti preoccupare la tiro io voterò fuori
totti e non faceva c'è eccolo è stato
bravo questo ne va facendo benissimo
vuoi laila toccanti dimmi che ci sei non
ho peccato
mamma mia se mi di scartava ti prometto
fabi che migliorerò mai fatto un gol e
siamo 3 2 grazie a te figure dovrò
diventare un pro anch'io
guarda che contro io ho preso il toro va
in mezzo si riusciva all'arrivo prendo
un po di boot
cioè lui che vola ma grazie lo fa lo
spinge però c è ora non ho tirato forte
non depistato perché se ci si aspettava
una mina invece
ma di segnalazione bellissimo ma proprio
motorino dominante tutte le partite che
si vada via livello bravissimi
bravissimi ma che partita
bravi bene bene ragazzi the fame un
altro paio per adesso solo vittorie per
i nostri amici qua nello special dice
ragazzi questa è questa è la sua
livellando guarda a livello 4 3.500 expo
buono ragazzi sono contentissimo f
significare spectre ragazzi rispetto
ecco perché lasciate piena però vabbè
per gli avversari in questo caso va bene
allora provaci [ __ ] incornano niente
contrati mi piace sempre provare a fare
questa cosa o quest'ultima attenzione
tbl leggo se li battiamo ragazzi vuol
dire sì battle ori e invece non sanno
che abbiamo il grassone non lo sanno non
se l'aspettano
ecco vedi quest'anno vincitore tornei ok
il gr1 e ora una silver data non vai vai
vai vai là contesto per me i ragazzi se
lo vincesse la vinco chiudiamo la suap
challenge a top
anzitutto innanzitutto palo lo dice
innanzitutto prendiamo un vantaggio
almeno siamo più tranquilli de palo ok
contestato no no vediamo serali tocca e
mezzo buono sono un babbo proprio sono
completamente non giocanti questo
bravissimo gravissimo gravi crollato
a dirlo è del grasso ne grasso ne da
sotto ci ho provato
grazie è grande adesso anche allora ve
l'ho detto a tempo di vado male se lo
dico ragazzi in realtà non è la mia
prima partita sulle rotte league ma io
ho giocato tutti i libri quando uscì per
il ps plus mi sembra fu uno dei primi
giochi per ps plus nella ps4
ma se non mi ricordo può essere io la
faccio iniziato a giocare io io giocavo
a quello prima che aveva un nome che era
era un nome impronunciabile schiava
supersonic acrobatic rocket powered
batte il cast e lo giuro playstation 3
si si è poi diventato rock etnica quando
è uscito ds4 con diciamo i giochi del ps
plus quei due giochi al mese che davano
nello scaricare ci fece qualche partita
sul ps però adesso sostiene nostre cose
e poi soprattutto non va bene
questo gruppo di del meraviglioso
dunque grande cene senza per avere
appena aperto per aver la pena riavviato
durant a rho sono contentissimo ma
quello cielo ferrari che figli
ma sì che a me non piace invece perché è
un xbox città strana dove va bene
mammamia andata lì e non si sa come dall
obiettivo meraviglioso meraviglioso raga
ragazzi sognano 16.000 like riportiamo
la contesa è vero vero 10.000 ragazzi
arriva
per la sua challenge di vodafone 2.0
questa virtù all'arena deve arrivare a
10mila like importante questo milan
gamesweek particolarissimo entreremo
nella storia così certo che soprattutto
per il fatto che hai segnato tre i tre a
due adesso dobbiamo fare le 22 per loro
c'erano 22 pari volevo dire ok e poi
segnerà il 3 a 2 dai le forze come se no
non puoi signora è un ritorno rompiamo
le regole capito questa tentato un
controllo strano ma ho capito o no alla
fame da me perché i tuoi bagno armato
perché ti abbiamo fatto il tizio vediamo
gli ho toccato la palla e tu hai mai
fatto il tifo però hai fatto mai fatto
biliardo questo è tuo è andato a me ma
questo è tuo e tua figlia di cento nel
centro di grazia buono buono bella
giocata di trazione che lo spinge sulla
palla
la giorno dovrete gustibus tributo alla
valletta di recupera tutto cioè di la
valletta a lato c'era tutto il turno di
piccole piccole di ricomprano piccole
porzioni di turbo quindi sono diciamo
delle zone strategiche devi prendere
sempre mamma mia a palate graz
mamma mia cosa toni e quest'uomo cosa
toglie che cosa ho fatto mi sono
probabili
ok io vado al centro vai vai vai vai
spingi la mamma mia che bravo hai fatto
una roba che ai miei fatto segnare sei
un fenomeno me l'hai messa lì ma ragazzi
fanno istituzioni di partite siamo quasi
a 10.000 laiche mancano 150 ragazzi è il
momento di smerciare like perché in
questo momento la partita se lo merita
stasera non farò bruhl stasera farcelo
rete league
bellissimo no per niente e mi raccomando
la keys chiede il canale che tra 2000
iscritti arriviamo a 6 milioni e mezzo
per te che onore c'ero cherie mentre
siamo arrivati
oddio non era peccato il caldo caldo
caldo gli avrei potuto tirarla molto più
forte ma va bè quello fuori è la vera
dell'andata raggio di stagista va a
segnare il 3 a 2 ma ha insegnato
comunque hai segnato prima pole in
realtà comunque ragone rangon tuo quello
della nato né perché l'ho toccata per
ultimo tecnicamente dei nostri però è to
eye to eye spinto quello che non sulla
palla vi era un gol da biliardo è anche
difficile
attenzione attenzione no è persona nel
tempo però lì ci stava
bella ci stanno grazie super
concentrazione non vedrà la sua mamma ci
dice che stava entrando in porta portese
e non potranno più fare niente non
potevo fare niente
ecco comunque detto fatto che in un
secondo si area 10500 like 10.500 light
legal grazie mille per aver importato
incredibilmente st live grazie anche a
bola compare a vodafone svap challenge
2.0 vi ricordiamo la vodafone power
gating l'offerta viola fonti voleva
utilizzare per non sprecare igica mente
di giocate giugno by importante palla
nel mezzo prova a volare grazie a
facciamo qui partì proprio fare il fare
un polo live adesso ti spiego fa mi fa
un gol il bravissimo ma io pensavo non
ci fosse suonato con sufficienza invece
c'era e non ora quando guardo tutto
carico è macchinista la modella maligni
fascista normale se all'inizio senza che
sara è molto più difficile farlo in volo
per che coordina simboli casino se ti
fai dei voli agli show girl buonissimo
allora ti spiego aspettava devo fare un
altro gol però nell'altra porta però ok
ma volo fatto una cagata velo pin carla
non sei riuscito aspetta
la grande difesa
bravo bravo la porterà avanti fari cioè
percussione un minuto rimanente possiamo
anche senza gol e fare questa cosa
davvero un peccato allora aspetta che
rimane la un peccato c'ero ero certo
peccato c'era spiega spiega notevole
parlava allora è però manca un minuto
nel safe allora proverò a far devo fare
in altro gol
proverò a fartelo farina mesi può fare
allenamenti in due poi regala perché
almeno diciamo a fare sta cosa da
imparare a farlo volare vita nova e
toccherà tocca è tua non l'ho toccata un
passato che dai persone mamma mia mamma
mia grazie che non si fa perdere
tre ragazzi va da mare facendo arrivare
qua e bellissime online per loro allora
appena la palla la butta in avanti ti
faccio vedere come si vada tu prestagli
guarda gli occhi ma come si parla in
italiano tutorial salvatore aranzulla
punta gli occhi sul favi questo lo dico
guarda ti vedo allora spetta allora
aspettano adesso è perché adesso io devo
avere un attimo di serenità
serve perché adesso adesso guardami
allora guarda tu fai un salto ti pieghi
un attimo in avanti e schiacci cerchio
ha capito ai problemi ha chiesto dalla
fiera quindi cerchi sarebbe il buio ok
cacchio allora salti ti pieghi un attimo
come se volessi andare col muso in alto
e schiacciata sulle bustine pronte da
sempre a ok voli aspetta aspetta ma cosa
anche a caso più o meno capito che devi
mettere la macchina in verticale per
schiacciare il turbo come farlo però
come maschiacci allora il tasso di sala
ecco ci hai fatto e non t'ho visto
quanto ho visto è fighissimo ragazze
fossero leoni è infatti vorrei vederti
farlo e che molto divertente sai adesso
aspetta di vedere però farlo adesso però
fanno adesso si può fare vai esatto
esatto 6 laceno stai facendo male vedere
se riusciamo a fare eco allenamento se
volete fare a noi privata in privata la
dobbiamo fare
vediamo se ti fa entrare non ti fa
entrare vero la facciamo privata un
ottimo attore nei menu aspetto che mi
stanno regalando macchina mi prendi la
vediamo che cirelli non si trovi ora no
bellissima cosa hai trovato aftershock
molto hard ciò che non è male
ora gioca rifacciamo allena e incontri
personalizzati partita privata che la
partita privata
1 v1 mettiamo poi che mi piace al grasso
ne voglio vedere come può la sea ha
assegnato a volare questa la via che lo
sarà questa domenica vediamo questa
maniera la mia preferita è il calore
know i'm alive gamefly dai aspetta un
attimo default
ok posso prendere tipico perfetto vice
allora bilaterale la pace
ok allora proventi entrato ti sta
entrando se il sesso in corso meno che
perfetto allora fai auto caricamento
arrivo ci sono allora adesso prendi il
turbo che sta dietro di te ne subito se
dove c'è stata la vergogna del nome voli
ok prendi il turbo
ok allora guarda me ora guarda tutti i
piedi una salti così innanzitutto se
quando sai te lo faccia step quando
salti ti pieghi in avanti così tipo
retromarcia sulla retromarcia di un velo
è poi tieni premuto cerchio quindi bus
mamma va p allora ci provo stato
leggermente era però devo tenere
comunque di e nobile aspetta non è
necessario non è necessario non ti
aspetta che non si trovano più o meno ho
capito perché recupero boost e non è
facile non è facile una facile ma non è
facile ci sono non è facile all'inizio è
normale e vabbè è lo so è un casino
ecco che grassone esatto e tu quando fai
questa cosa dovresti fare con la palla
tipo aspetta che devi essere super
coordinato devi fare una roba un po
aspetta di soprattutto europeo che hai
fatto
quindi tu quando fai questa roba di di
provare a prendere la palla che è un
casino
non so riuscita alzare aspetta il
momento di brutto bellissimo providence
ice prende la palla
aspetta aspetta il calcio aprendo vyp
roma 5 mar
aspetta aspetta spetta vai adesso è
normale normale al macello macello days
ha dato una volta ma è normale
all'inizio è proprio un casino
e se c'è chi vuole al contrario cefa
delle robe che non esistono cioè tanto
ti sto insegnando meglio sorvolare in
modo mediocre cei non sono io ti ripeto
non faccio ecco però per il controllo
questo guarda scusa adesso quando che tu
stai sul pallone e te lo giri questa
cosa qua è molto bravo madonna
hai fatto lei fatta forti difficile
adesso era fatta bravissimo e quello che
ne so io e te lo tieni vicino a te e te
lo tieni parole vessare la palla
veramente soprannome delle strane
dipende dal tipo di controllo perché
allora ti faccio vedere vediamo sensecam
parte lo stato
allora vieni vieni qua residenti
aspettano non sulla palla io prendo il
turbo sondrio guarda e speriamo che non
sia scappata roba scoprendo un mondo
fino allora se la palla ti arriva
addosso pian piano fabri grande problema
si diventa ora alzi marcello lo so ne
rendo conto però tu puoi fare questa
cosa ha capito qual è questo qua secondo
me all'inizio il più difficile che
volare è sì ma ancor più difficile prova
avere esattamente aspetta dove andare
contro la palla ok lo so è un macello
però devi prova devi andare piano piano
piano bravo bravo gira gira al aspetta
aspetta vi faccio vedere devi andare
proprio piano sulla palla aspetta dove
si può andare allora aspetta ti metti in
relazione goverso avverso la palla che
ti arriva incontro sia questo caso è
troppo lenta però parla dice lupi anno
con questo te la porti in giro dove
cacchio vuoi praticamente questa cosa
qua è utilissima nei dribbling
e se sei uno dei tanti come un birillo
provera vini pazzesco perché questa roba
puoi fare quello che vuoi esaltarlo e in
base a dove va la palla per mettetela
sul tetto cosa fai
in base a dove va tu vai verso contro la
palla e travail salire sopra guarda
certo lateralmente capito questa cosa
qua non è difficile sia una volta che
impari a farla è poi mentre giochi
quando vedi gli altri distanti fai
subito questo perché ti prende un
vantaggio incredibile riporti a spasso
quelli arrivano a 3500 st ekdal attico
dribbling tiri smart its ragazzi fanno
l'ultima vai ultima la vinciamo la gara
e ci dai the last one
allora quando una partita ci sono
ragazzi l'onore di avere un training
ma questa è proprio una base è proprio
fatti capire come si fanno queste due
ruote
io sono io faccio molto più questo che è
che il volo perché il volo ci sono molti
modi modi di volare c'è chi l'ha
compensa c'è il controllo aereo per
farti capire cioè delle ruspe che si
siano mai idea di come sono che la gente
però di avere proprio un controllo su di
avere un controllo veramente assurdo
però io io mi baso su quello al terreno
e rimango lì perché sennò proprio dai
famosi non siamo andati bene possiamo
perderla vince chi se ne frega
sono stato veramente contento di come i
giocato e sono orgoglioso punto che è
uscita fuori una cosa incredibile
terribile incredibile allora c'è alberto
sniper addirittura il 15 di snai per
aver forza probabile vai vai bravo
alzata e adesso però a chiamare o però
da fare un po troppo stop in casa mini
fabi aspetta adesso ragazzi ci diciamo
l'assetto nuovo so più velocità
qui
bush aspetta con quello non c'era ma
vabbè quale per andare arrivare in
anticipo sulla palla ho volato sopra
perché sennò mi arriva troppo lenta
addosso rapido quindi paolo ii si sia
messo niente realtà c'è chi guarda ai
campini nei campionati del mondo vedi
robe che non ha idea
vai vai però ci fa e l'ho presa troppo
alta buon lavoro pure permesso
ok il corpo valore guardava da dato
fastidio
hai capito che questo tipo di controllo
funziona spesso di te la metti sopra
quell'ora arriva appena appena ti viene
addosso fi hsdpa lo salvano avanti e non
splitter avanti nei seguenti ci sta lì
sta ci sta
va bene c'erano delle facile ma mi va
bene dobbiamo far uscire tutti e due
papà ancora una felice se è per questo
che sono vale 5 su 5 però è sulla carta
mammamia oggi incredibile ragazzi che
svap challenge ma che che emozione che
cosa vuol dire mi consigli di giocare da
joystiq per sempre allora io ti dico la
maggior parte delle persone giocano
giocano da joystiq io personalmente con
la tastiera non saprei fare ma niente
c'è poi non fa bene anche a voi provo ma
non prendiamo subito delle scoppole
incredibili
perché io purtroppo con la tastiera non
avendo mai giocato non certo come
persino un altro sistema e tra e credo
che a livello mondiale ci siano poche
persone che giocano con la tastiera però
qualcuno c'è ma c'è qualcuno sicuro
probabilmente col con l'analogico riesce
a gestirla meglio riesce a fare i
movimenti più fluidi e normale si può
essere capito e quello disco non
esattamente per quello che non è solo
perché ho giocato
se questo non va tra non mi fa uscire
come dici riprende la partita che non
tornano se lo fa perché perché non è
ancora in partita
aspetta da carlo che sono pronte appena
parte anche lei mi sa che ci sono
intrippati perché sono uscito abbandona
la partita ci sono vai dicevo nel senso
ha giocato un sacco di volte a giochi
sul pc ripoli prospeed eccetera
però colpa ad un'altra cosa col volante
meglio però questo è un altro gioco
ok va bene bella swan
ci siamo ragazzi questa è la partita
questa è la partita definitiva la vita
la vita si vola ti ringraziamo compito
così si parte col palo attenzione 2 la
se questo metallo libere tutto questo
ora come ha portato questo è vero sì
questo qua ne sapeva di più però magari
poi la palla a terra bacio ma i gas
tutto a posto tutto calcolato
ringraziamo davvero ripeto con quello
che ha detto grazie ad iphone che ci
permetteva sboccia lenge le vittorie ma
ho fatto questo pomeriggio così
particolare meraviglioso ragazzi carica
la canzone vado è vero che non ho
tantissima lo era mi hanno demolito
arrivo prendo il gusto quello massimo
lei lei lo sa che se spesso giusto
spetta davi bam pato si chiama bump sta
roba praticamente pinci senza demolirlo
che comunque dà fastidio da siena invece
avviene se lo prendi col gusto
la definizione sulla tv col bus si pian
piano ragazzi che tuttavia ha aggiunto
al coro questa bravo per eppure sogniamo
va bene va bene va bene bene sì e non ho
turbo vela da prendere mostra che lo
prenderemo trendence vai vai tocca tocca
bravo troppo sotto l'attuale bel ago la
partita da fare un gol da fare
hai fatto sempre un gol a partita per
ora si nota la prima miss a problemi che
ne va bene adesso riuscito quindi si è
il momento
perfetto vai carica l'arrivo sono carico
io a farvi l'alza madonna mamma non la
potrà togliere mai questa cioè si chiamò
da togliere ma senza powers impennata
dopo proprio quando fai impennata poi
anche farla capriole in avanti che la
mia giusto valles gol alla devo cercare
esatto riprende bene parla o che sbaglio
che ho fatto ha pregato il bus però
d'altro vallelunga è importante che
siamo a posto
ok se va giù arrivo e ho sbagliato io
quelli vanno giù delle mie orta ciao
queste gol non toglierò mai perdere il
bus grandissimo ma non era vero modo di
toglierla mabruk 16 mag un look ai
locali scorda gol praticamente noi
possiamo chiudere quello sconfitte no no
assolutamente
it's the moment
e vabbè qua è andata bene perché la
partenza non la prima dei ragazzi e zap
per farvi che cosa sta capitando quella
fatta una partenza un po strano
effettivamente però lo si punisce
perfetto tempismo perfetto chieti nella
questo mi ormai vai vai vai belli siamo
venuti a rubare almeno l'ho colpito
carico male però garantito per chi era
sorta di rocchetti libero fatta pure sul
gas cioè è vero partito quello di denis
ma come si chiama paul pohl folli quella
che decide esatto si che è uguale a rho
che si fanno prendere o meno ci stava
solo che qui la parla un po più alto ero
un pochino pc il nuovo turbo giovane
povero di mal di mare per far segnare
l'altro è affatto bene mi ha fatto che
mi stesse bump andò toglierà del poteva
toglierla tranquillamente solo chi vuole
mi avvampa vami mi ha fatto preoccupare
ma hanno capito che sei cardiaco di
brutto e quindi buttano da uno dei punti
fuori puntuali si fa lo stesso fa lo
stesso si fa lo stesso se ci credo io ci
credo ci crediamo ad alta quella aia
dovrebbe farlo tolta lo stesso ok
vado a farlo bravo foto troppo sotto
bravo si è andata benissimo perché lei
bampa tuta è andata mi hai preso un
tempo perfetto non basta io l'ho buttato
in mezzo ma questa bonato mezza mappa
cioè è infatti ha finito il turbo spero
è che tiro 6 canali legge preoccupare
per di latisana e successo calma di
errore allora ok ok perfetto perfetto e
la era misti niente milano non pare
io non lo turba per fare niente però ci
prova lo stesso bravi scusami sarebbe
stato un gol perché stavo libro infatti
scusami ti sto dicendo scusami 71
studiate avrebbe dovuto
io la volevo farti segnare non ci avevo
pensato perché ho detto almeno ci crede
vai vai posso fare lo posso fare gli si
butta nel nostro automatico bello bello
niente ma demolito occhi è poi difficile
prova a difenderlo ma ci credo che abbia
buttato la torta però non ce la faccio
più o meno anzi va bene basta è bastato
noto il dato può essere demolite non
sono è che avevo fatto ciao ragazzi io
ho visto un bello spettacolo diciamo
solo che però qualche golletto è ma si
può fare si può fare ancora mancano 50
secondi spiega non sorrentino
adesso c'è il momento di farlo è il
momento del gol finale di craxi e il
momento di coordinare si può fare un
sogno non abbiamo persone anche 100
incredibile e questi sanno anche volare
quel fatto ora allora proviamoci
proviamoci come fermare con le ferrovie
dai vai vai vento tanto tolgo tira però
è toccata
noi dobbiamo solo toccata ti prego io lo
posso fare anche in toglie la voglia
togliere a toglierli sotto precisa non
mi ero lì fermo intento rilevare tutti
tagliate processava dai 40 secondi
quaranta secondi rimanere fino alla fine
importantissimo mi sa che ci abbiamo un
altro un altro di spostare domanda e
adesso vediamo poi sono ripartiti perché
quello ci credevo che quello pensa che
mi si è addormentato tira tira prova ci
va bene gli aidepi stati gli ha guardati
erano pronti a difendere un super tiro
quando ho visto grazia che saputo al
cappio entrava attenzione lo stato
yuppie e la sera potremo togliere non
l'ho tolta perché le tombe tanto da
fuori sono stati unti non ho capito che
sarà potuto
essere qui ci stava non è stato un babbo
però occhio perché non cedono fa 5555
molto fake non ho giocato però vai vai
vai cosa rimasto fermo aveva fregato
buono 15 secondi sono pochi o quello
tentato demolizione ma non è riuscito
attenzione classe dove si sa perché era
portata lo importa che è successo non ho
visto niente
c'è veramente la tirata sull'angolo
lingua per riprenderla saputo è un
bambino e babbo questa chiaro è stato
barbon penso al sistina poteva chiudere
con la toccavo ok secondi dai dai quei
pancia in di secondi ci credo io ci
credo 10 salato stalin sta lì da molto
in mezzo provaci ultimazione
non so se ce la faccio a tutti
gigi pro lavoro prova col finale
provarlo finale è affatto di cavi mille
di media a partita incredibile però
abbiamo giocato molto bene mi sei
piaciuto anche perché abbiamo vinto
tutte le partite
superstar da abbiamo vinto un miliardo
insegnato a volare a controllare tutto
abbiamo fatto tutto questo successo
quando ora e mezza di puro godimento e
che dobbiamo fare un regalo se manca una
pompa per gaming ragazzi marca di fare
quella poi abbiamo finito cioè
totalmente dopo ragazzina live così mi
raccomando fate un salto sul sito a
vedere appunto quali sono i giochi che
sono compresi nell'offerta però abbiamo
già abbastanza per stare al gioco di
punta quindi si trova praticamente se
ragazzi spero che questa live view vi
sia piaciuta io ringrazio mister b max
per aver partecipato
ringrazio vodafone per sbocciare il
punto zero collaborazione italia questa
virtù all arena del business week che
abbiamo portato per giocare sia con
tasche rocket lì che si è rivelata un
successo pazzesco sono molto siamo
entrati nella storia della prima
edizione così purtroppo obbligati però
siamo abituati a fare gli eventi dal
vivo incontrarvi magari la sicurezza è
riposata perché la solita sicurezza
lavora un botto grazie
io vi ringrazio ragazzi per aver
partecipato ancora una volta noi ci
vediamo come sempre martedì il giovedì e
la domenica in live perché io sono in
quei giorni la questa domenica anche
passare anche nei cracks e vi mando un
bacione e ci chiamano re pavia non
arrivino a casa tutti i ragazzi